[Música]
como se puede apreciar yo con este
cuerpo y con esta piel claramente
pertenezco una generación anterior a la
de los millennials estos jóvenes
profesionales que a muchos les están
sacando canas a nivel laboral
sin embargo yo tengo un sobrino
millennial y a mí de verdad me preocupa
mucho el rechazo que sienten las
empresas por ellos como también debo
decir que me preocupa mucho la antipatía
que los millennials le tienen al mundo
organizacional
mi sobrino acaba de terminar la
universidad y tanto él como sus
compañeros de solo pensar en trabajar en
una empresa tradicional se les revuelve
el estómago
de casualidad conocen a alguien que esté
en esta misma situación
veo que sí bueno pues les voy a contar
tres cosas acerca de los millennials el
50 por ciento de los millennials es
decir la mitad de los millennials
preferirían no trabajar hoy en no
trabajar antes que tener un trabajo que
odiará
el 56% de ellos ni siquiera aceptaría un
trabajo en el cual se le prohibiera el
uso de las redes sociales y como si esto
fuera poco el 76 por ciento considera
que su jefe debería estar aprendiendo de
ellos
pero veamos quiénes son los millennials
más allá de todas estas estadísticas con
las que nos bombardean diariamente se
trata de los jóvenes profesionales que
según quién nacieron entre 1980 y el
2000 y comenzaron a trabajar con el
cambio de milenio cuantos millennials
tenemos hoy en la sala
bien
chicos ustedes comparten el sitio de
trabajo con dos generaciones
principalmente la generación x que somos
los que nacimos entre 1963 y 1969 cuánto
x power aquí
y antes que nosotros llegaron los baby
boomers que son personas que nacieron en
tiempos difíciles en tiempos de
posguerra es decir entre 1946 y 1962
cuántos baby boomers hoy
con poca menos bueno señor el descuento
que ustedes antes solían ser la mayoría
en las empresas y por eso el modelo
organizacional tradicional está muy
cercano a sus corazones a las de las
personas mayores de 50 años
sin embargo a partir del 2015
los millennials los igualaron ya han
comenzado a ser la nueva mayoría de las
empresas según las encuestas se
considera perdón según las proyecciones
se considera que el 75 por ciento de la
fuerza laboral en tan sólo seis años
sólo seis años serán millennials 75% el
futuro se ve muy milenio y mientras
tanto los x y los boomers vamos camino
al retiro y el estilo actual de las
organizaciones pierde vigencia porque la
forma en que nos educaron a nosotros y
el contexto histórico que nos ha tocado
vivir es muy diferente al que les ha
tocado a ellos por ejemplo nosotros
estábamos acostumbrados a ver la tele en
familia a compartir un solo televisor yo
recuerdo los domingos sentados con mis
hermanos y además negociando el canal
que íbamos a ver de los dos que había
claro está porque no era que hubiera más
mientras que ellos crecieron con
televisión en el cuarto conexión las 24
horas teléfono propio muchos incluso
son hijos únicos y ni siquiera han
tenido que compartir los juguetes
nosotros en cambio crecíamos con la ropa
heredada de los hermanos mayores y si se
nos rompía nos ponían los dichosos
parches que hoy en día salen así de
fábrica pero en esa época era cero
cubrir de llevar
pero todas estas comodidades son gracias
a que la mujer lideró uno de los cambios
más importantes de los últimos tiempos
las de nuestra generación y fue la
entrada al mercado laboral
esto implicó que tras la baja de
maternidad tuvieran que volver al lugar
de trabajo y organizar las dinámicas
familiares en una forma totalmente
diferente a la que les había tocado a
ellas entonces comenzó una búsqueda
desesperada por actividades
extracurriculares para que los chicos
pudieran estar entretenidos mientras
ambos padres estaban fuera de casa por
cuenta del trabajo los pusimos a
aprender de deporte de música de mates e
incluso los pusimos a aprender durante
las vacaciones y esto ha hecho que la
nueva generación sean unos chicos con
una gran necesidad de aprender y de
hecho la generación con más estudios de
toda la historia para ellos tener una
carrera y máster y dos idiomas y conocer
varios países es como un denominador
en este momento tenemos sentada en las
empresas a la generación con más
preparación de todos los tiempos piensa
cómo puedes aprovechar todos esos
conocimientos
y yo mientras tanto te cuento de un
segundo colateral de la entrada de la
mujer al mercado laboral que fue un
segundo sueldo en casa esto hace que los
millennials crezcan con absolutamente
todo lo que desean con consola con
diversión con entretenimiento con ropa
nueva y además con psp pero resulta que
ellos comienzan a extrañar eso que antes
había y ya no hay sus padres en los
momentos importantes de sus vidas
los millennials crecieron con un tiempo
muy limitado con sus padres y lo
resienten a ellos les hubiera gustado
verlos más compartir más cosas
muchos de ellos inclusive los vieron
enfermos por cuenta del trabajo
y esto ha hecho que ellos no quieran
perpetuar ese círculo con sus hijos si
bien para un milenio la realización
profesional es importante también lo es
la realización personal y eso es algo
que no están dispuestos a sacrificar
aquí ocurren dos cosas muy importantes
la primera es que ocurre un cambio en la
definición de éxito porque para nosotros
los mayores de 40 el éxito estaba dado
por todo lo que pudiéramos acumular por
cuenta del trabajo una casa coche y
buena educación para los hijos y
vacaciones en la playa y para lograr
todo esto teníamos que estudiar una
carrera que nos diera los medios con que
vivían
y allí nos resignamos
y aceptamos trabajos y carreras que no
necesariamente eran los que nos hubieran
gustado de hacer simplemente porque
queríamos cumplir con este sueño
colectivo de hecho yo recuerdo a un
profesor de marketing que nos decía
señores es que si el trabajo fuera bueno
a uno no le pagarían por hacerlo
veo que no fue la única
y justo eso ha hecho que nosotros les
inculcamos a ellos una cosa que quisimos
compensar esa frustración que tenemos
nosotros cuando se fueron a grabar del
colegio les dimos un solo consejo y fue
busca tu felicidad laboral que lo que
hagas y lo que estudies te haga feliz no
importa cuál sea el camino que tú
decidas seguir futbolista cocinero
abogado médico yo te voy a apoyar porque
yo quiero que tú seas feliz y se los
inculcamos si se los encontramos y se
los inculcamos
y a mí me sorprende que hoy en día
seamos nosotros los que nos burlamos
cuando ellos defienden su derecho a ser
felices en el trabajo que fue tal cual
se los machacamos
los millennials nos han obedecido en
esto de la forma en que nosotros
obedecíamos a nuestros padres se
acuerdan que antes uno tenía que acatar
órdenes sin chistar
la relación con los padres que son los
primeros referentes de autoridad y en
buena parte marcarán lo que es la
relación de los jóvenes con los jefes es
una de las cosas que más ha cambiado la
nuestra era lejana distante a nosotros
nos decían chicos suecia el coche y nos
subíamos que vamos a comer que a mí nos
gusta el pollo se lo come a nosotros
nadie nos preguntaba absolutamente nada
esto ha hecho que nosotros queramos
compensar con los jóvenes y resulta que
nos volvimos la generación de yo quiero
ser amigo de mis hijos
tanto hombres como mujeres hoy tienen
una relación mucho más cercana conocen
el nombre de la maestra que les cae mal
conocen la niña que les gusta cuáles son
los amigos mi papá no tenían ni idea de
cómo se llamaban mis amigos
y por eso te pregunto cómo es tu
relación con ese millennial que se
levanta todos los días a trabajar para
ti es así de cercano
conoces algo
ya sé que en nuestra época la relación
con la jerga con la autoridad y las
jerarquías era más que todo como de
rendición de cuentas como cuando uno
llegaba del colegio con el boletín pues
si nos portamos mal nos castigaban si
suspendíamos una asignatura pues la
repetimos en esa época nadie iba ni al
psicopedagogo ni tenía problemas de
atención ni hacia terapias con las
carencias que tuviéramos nosotros
hacíamos lo que podíamos y aceptamos las
consecuencias de nuestros actos
sin embargo para los millennials ha
habido un acompañamiento ellos han
tenido tutores terapias e incluso muchos
padres que se pelean con los profes
simplemente para defenderlos cada vez
que un millenials se ha tropezado hemos
estado ahí dispuestos a levantarlo y por
eso ellos esperan que en el trabajo
también haya un jefe que lo ayude a
desarrollarse cuando un miller ya no lo
encuentra se frustra porque no sabe cómo
defenderse porque el mundo en el que
vivía era diferente
y normalmente te pregunto
como estás ayudando tú a tus jóvenes
colaboradores a superar esos pequeños
retos que tienen en el día a día
porque no se te olvide como ellos te
ayudan a ti a superar los tuyos por
ejemplo en materia de tecnología porque
si algo ha cambiado en estos tiempos ha
sido la tecnología que nosotros nos
tenían de hecho prohibido acercarnos a
la tecnología no podíamos ni tocar ni el
equipo de sonido ni la videocasetera que
para los millennials que me escuchan son
los dinosaurios precursores del mp3 y el
mp4
en algunos aparatos así de grandes que
además eran costosísimos y difíciles de
conseguir
y resulta que ahora son ellos los que
saben absolutamente todo y ya quienes
acudimos para que nos resuelvan las
dudas de hecho yo cada vez que tengo
algún dilema tecnológico consulto por
internet e invariablemente me lo
resuelve un chico de 12 años
y aquí ocurren dos cosas que son bien
interesantes la primera es que hay una
inversión de roles en la que los adultos
comenzamos a aprender de los jóvenes
y la segunda es que ellos se dan cuenta
que nosotros no nos la sabemos todos
sería espectacular si en las empresas
tuvieran la misma humildad para
preguntarle a ellos por su perspectiva
y no me refiero solamente a el tema
tecnológico porque hay muchas cosas que
se pueden capitalizar los millennials en
general tuvieron una educación mucho más
potente que la nuestra lo cual es
absolutamente normal todo padre quiere
que su hijo llegue más lejos de lo que
él llegó toda madre quiere que su hijo
tenga lo que ella no tuvo y por eso les
pagamos formaciones en donde pudieran
aprender a pensar a discernir a
cuestionar a que no tuvieran que tragar
entero como nos tocó a nosotros y qué
pasa cuando un millennial cuestiona los
procedimientos de la compañía un
catástrofe de proporciones mayores con
derecho a pataleta del jefe y de
recursos humanos
y es que las empresas siguen muy
apegadas hacer las cosas en la misma
forma de siempre incluso a mantener
ambientes de trabajo competitivos en el
cual se alcanzan las metas corporativas
de manera aislada es decir si yo cumplo
mi meta y tú no cumples la tuya para mí
no es problema y el bono me lo llevo yo
o viceversa te lo llevas tú pero aquí
ganar todos no se va a poder
y ellos en cambio crecieron en el mundo
de la wikipedia
es un mundo de economía colaborativa en
el cual cuando todos ponemos nuestro
granito de arena construimos algo mucho
más grande que nosotros mismos
sí joana sarmiento me hubiera sentado a
registrar solamente mis conocimientos
nunca hubiera sido algo tan potente tan
poderoso como lo que tenemos hoy en día
y esta disposición que tienen los
millennials están muy bien capitalizada
por startups de turismo y de taxis y de
domicilios
ellos saben que tienen que dar una idea
y los millennials están dispuestos a
montarse para poder hacer expandir el
negocio
como estás haciendo tú para expandir tu
negocio con tus milenios
y yo te hago todas estas preguntas
porque a mí de verdad me causa mucha
curiosidad ver como el mundo que tenían
los millennials en la academia y en la
casa desaparece tan pronto dan un paso
en la empresa es como si se quedara allá
atrás en un mundo paralelo yo día a día
veo como estos jóvenes profesionales se
van frustrando de no poder aportar con
todo eso que ellos se han preparado para
hacer
ante sus ojos la única salida es huir de
las empresas que son el motor de este
planeta
díganme a quién le vamos a legar las
empresas
si seguimos espantando los
díganme por favor quién se va a encargar
del producto interno bruto en el futuro
o peor aún quién va a pagar nuestras
jubilaciones
esto a todas luces es un legado
insostenible o no
pero tratarán qué pasaría si tratáramos
a los millennials que tenemos en la
oficina exactamente igual que a los que
tenemos en la casa
es una solución sencilla económica y
super fácil de implementar para que
todos estos muchachos que se encuentra
absolutamente desenganchado se sientan
atraídos por el mundo corporativo y por
aportar a la seguridad social
eso
es sostenible señores los millenials nos
necesitan y el mundo necesita los
millenials
hoy los quiero invitar a que cada cual
desde donde esté ponga su granito de
arena para que entre todos construyamos
algo mucho más grande que nosotros
mismos
un modelo organizacional en el que se
respete lo que hemos hecho en el pasado
y además se honren los valores de
quienes serán nuestro relevo
generacional
un modelo de negocio en el que todas las
generaciones puedan vivir armónicamente
qué podemos hacer como sociedad para que
las empresas converjan esos valores que
les inculcamos en la casa
qué puedes hacer tú como madre tú como
jefe y tú como ciudadana para que todo
esto que estamos hablando hoy no se
quede solamente en
palabras
no se queden quietos hagan que suceda
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]